hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
the Destiny to gameplay reveal has given
us a remarkably in-depth look at the
changes advances and general evolution
of the franchise just in case you didn't
have chance to watch bungees livestream
here are 10 things you should know about
destiny 2 let's start with a new
Guardian sub client if you're a deathly
veteran or a newcomer to the series
you've no doubt noticed the three super
abilities seen in the trailer and you
let us take a moment to admire how damn
Stacey they are the Warlocks dawn blade
allows it wielder to fire flaming sword
swings at the enemies below the titan
Sentinel ability lets them become Annie
on Captain America with shield in hand
whether that's up close and personal or
as a projectile and my beloved one to
receive the arc Strider which summons
our staff and allows the holder to move
like a gymnastic machine 10 shades of
got out of anyone close enough these
awesome visuals lead me on to my next
point the new cinematic story the
traveler also known as the giant golf
ball in disguise gave us our light-based
powers well in destiny - the main
antagonist isn't happy with the
travelers decision and intends to use a
hostile takeover of the traveler and
it's light and enjoy through the red war
campaign we'll be working closely with
the three technibond guard characters
and finally we can really interact with
them and see them fight for the cause
we've been assured we'll see proper
character development in destiny - with
more cutscenes cinematic interactions
and story missions than ever before if
we have a new story then we need new
locations - and we've been told about
four busbar the European dead zone may
sound like something to do with
breakfast but it's in fact the home or
refuge area where humanity has decided
to set up shop and begin to rebuild
their lives over on Saturn's moon
actually named Titan is where you'll
find the viola also known as chrome dome
or is that just me the civilization here
is built upon the ocean with struts and
pillars holding up all the architects
Cady's over on Messrs which is overrun
by defects and the typical structures
they created during the first game and
the final location io is the moon of
Jupiter which is a sacred place to
Guardian and warlock in particular so
that's where you'll find I Cora making a
return our patrols allowing you to
organically move around each location
three player strike missions make a
return up do end game activities such as
night falls and race in addition to this
there are also something new
lost sectors which are like hidden
dungeons to buy true side missions if
you will with a boss and Luke stashes at
the end with me if you play destiny one
you know how damn right annoying it is
to send half your life in orbit its
accessing mission well we've been
assured that this is a thing of the past
and all PvE missions can be accessed
with boots on the ground
this will implemented through a new map
system which we'll see much more of in
the future a new slant on player versus
player was hinted at to switching from 6
vs 6 to 4 on 4 supposedly this makes
things easier to group up and play but
I'm a little skeptical of this and
expecting bigger lobbies rather than
smaller ones I'm sure this point will be
ironed out soon but Luke Smith did say
we're moving all activities in PvP too
far before he went on to state that the
crucible has been rebuilt for smaller
team formats this really does worry me
but let's keep this as positive as
possible we're also getting an
additional feedly P game-mode centered
around attacking and defending specific
points on each map the concept of
community came up many times in the
presentation mainly from social elite
empty killer who may now be the love of
my life after Kade of course she gave
was a lovely insight into clans and
guided games the easiest way to break
this down is by approaching it like
tinder
not that I know what that is of course
basically you can check out clans who
give a brief explanation about
themselves and you can even join or
swipe on to find another one when you do
finally choose a clan everything you do
will help that
clan on longer items which you will all
be awarded so if you can only make it
online once a week in theory you are
still contributing to the cause just
destiny 2 will offer bucket loads of
loot to collect whether that armor
weapons or sparrows but I wanted to look
at a new weapon system for a little more
clarity the three weapons locks are
coming back on the first time look
instead of primary secondary and heavy
it's now kinetic energy and power
weapons life this may not sound like a
big change but we may be forced to pick
between a sniper rifle or a grenade
launcher tough choice a kinetic weapon
would typically use just run-of-the-mill
bullets but the energy slot is the
weapon infused with elemental damage
like electricity or fire or as destiny
one gamers will know them as arc solar
and void on the plus side the kinetic
and energy slot can be used for the same
weapon type so if you love your hand
cannon why not bring two of them this
will give everyone's Guardians the most
freedom to choose the weapons they
really want to bring but also the stress
of leaving a weapon behind the
PlayStation will be receiving exclusive
items which won't be going to xbox or pc
but expect pc to receive key bindings
benefits or other three support options
only pcs can really support hopefully
you guys on xbox will get something
unique too oh and by the way PC users
you'll be using blizzards battlenet for
your game you never know this could lead
to a crossover - anyway I'm getting
sidetracked destiny tea will release on
September the 8th on all platforms with
a beta coming earlier in the summer what
do you think about destiny - are you
grabbing it if you need a clan come join
me in the ninja bread man I am Adam from
Playstation grenade I'll see you next
time